i forgot how gorgeous this place is
this guy breaks into my house
and you just sit down on the couch okay
but how about you you let go of my wife
first
and i've had to hold his hand how does
this open is there a trick to the purse
no there's a clasp
and help him rob us
i want a hundred fifty thousand dollars
you think that's enough
yeah i think you're probably gonna want
more than that
i can get you the money tomorrow
what
what me
i owe you something right
[Music]
you owe a debt to a hell of a lot more
people than just me
[Music]
try being a rich white guy these days it
sucks
do you want to be me
is that it you're pathetic
[Music]
i don't think you're going to do
anything
ever
you need to get close to him do whatever
it takes that's it
[Music]
your life is picture perfect
picture-perfect
nothing feels fair you have everything
and i have nothing
you did something that jeopardized me
get into the office right now i didn't
take anything that wasn't mine
you're not a killer
what you think you have to do next
please don't cross that line
[Music]
it's gonna be a long night
[Music]
you